prevenção do Alzheimer dentro do Óleo de
coco temos uma substância chamada
triglicerídeos de cadeia média ou TCM no
inglês a sigla é MCT que é a estrela na
prevenção e até no tratamento do
Alzheimer age como o escudo protetor
para os neurônios ele vira uma coisa
chamada cetonas ou copos cetônicos e
adivinha nossos neurônios amam cetonas
elas protegem contra o estresse
oxidativo e dão um Boost na nossa função
cognitiva
sendo super benéficas para quem tem
demência ou Alzheimer uma revisão de
2020 destaca o papel do TCM na prevenção
do Alzheimer justamente por suas
propriedades neuroprotetoras
antiinflamatórias e antioxidantes na
doença de alzheimer a pessoa tem
dificuldade para usar glicose como
energia em certas áreas do cérebro e é
aí que entram acetonas que funcionam
como uma fonte Alternativa de energia
podendo auxiliar nos sintomas da doença